[Music]  of that oh  i have water but it's not really cold do  you have water with you  very questionable for a previous  daughter  for horses with marijuana 421a  depression history of 405 feet  can you make sure the unit's responding  to the walmart f428  the same location 5200 south portland  has a 15 ago in the bathroom here's  twenty-one seven was filmed under the  stall in the bathroom  and unknown suspect that was that asian  male hit  forty five seven median bills i know for  a shirt right  i know playing for four for 12 minutes  right in front of the business with the  2l a bfa black shirt  and blue pants let's go  two hours last night and contact the  system on this possible 428  uh